Hello and welcome to the concert hall in
Stockholm where this year's Nobel
laureates received their awards from the
king of Sweden for their outstanding
contributions to science and economics.
And they join us small and elite group.
And this is the first time that there'll
be a pairing together on TV.
And we've also invited the family and
friends to our audience as well as some
of the best and brightest students from
across Stockholm.
And they will be putting their questions
and comments to our laureates.
Well,
this year we have discoveries in the
development of small machines,
a thousand times thinner than a strand
of hair.
Can you believe that?
We also delve into strange forms of
matter that could lead to super false
computing and does it make economic
sense to pay bosses,
big checks,
salaries,
bonuses,
that kind of thing while they're amongst
the topics that we'd be discussing.
But this year's Nobel laureates,
gentlemen,
welcome to your and renewed
congratulations to all of you.
No,
I hope you don't mind starting off by
saying that the average age of this
year's lawyers is 72 you're all 65 or
over.
And you know,
the trend is to award the Nobel prizes
later in life.
Do you think it's a good thing that you
should wait longer to be recognized for
your work?
Um,
I'll ask you first,
Oliver Hart because your father died at
the age of 106 and he published his most
significant scientific paper when he was
71.
It's true.
Yes.
I think he was going a little too slowly
actually.
But um,
to answer your question,
I think certainly in economics they tend
to want to be sure that the contribution
that I'm recognizing is,
is one that's going to survive the test
of time.
But then I can understand that because
things happen,
you know,
people get very excited about things.
Um,
so some sort of hot topic and then it
turns out,
you know,
five,
10 years later,
it doesn't seem so important.
So I think,
you know,
they often wait 30 years and that's
okay.
And that's going to lead to the kind of
ages you're talking about it which
people win prizes.
I mean,
could one of the reasons be that there's
so much theory now?
I mean,
apparently a hundred years ago there
were a thousand physicists and now there
were apparently a million.
What do the physicists think?
Did you think it takes longer for real
talent to shine through because there's
just so much information you've got to
assimilate?
I don't think it takes longer.
It's just as you say,
it's a matter of quantitative.
Miss so many smart physicists around
that.
How do you tell which piece of work is
going to be significant?
It's impossible.
Ben,
for anger as a chemist.
Do you think that,
um,
the prize acknowledges the kind of
benefits of incrementalism,
you know,
standing on the shoulders of giants as
it were,
and it kind of goes against the,
in Eureka moment in the bath that we
often associate with science,
of course we stand on the shoulders of
giants.
I mean,
we work with the knowledge that was
made,
uh,
experienced and developed before us.
But there are these certain moments
that,
uh,
in in time that my colleagues and myself
and others in the field experience where
you suddenly realize that you have made
a breakthrough and that opens up a new
field.
It might take several years before it's
recognized that a new field has been
opened.
But John Pierre has survived.
I mean,
you're a chemist,
but I could ask you this.
When we're thinking about drugs and
vaccines and that kind of thing.
I mean,
we do need fast science.
Do we to fix urgent problems?
I mean like the Zika virus or,
or whatever because you know,
you can't hang around for ages waiting
for vaccines.
Yeah,
you're absolutely right.
But,
um,
you know,
we are,
I think probably all of us around this
table,
basic scientists,
we are mostly interested in basic
science and um,
of course,
I mean the research we do,
I could lead to new drugs,
new vaccines and all that.
Um,
but in our everyday research who are
quite far away from that,
let me just see what the students in our
audience thinks.
Students,
just a couple,
a few comments from some of you about
sort of life in the fast lane,
the slow lane.
Because I mean,
the world that you inhabit today is
quite different from when these Nobel
laureate started studying.
I mean you've got,
you know,
instantly knowledge and information.
People talk about information overload,
the distractions,
the constant digital stimulation.
Um,
you know,
confusing inflammation with knowledge.
Who feels that perhaps we should have
more emphasis on longterm effort and
experience?
Oh,
uh,
I think that um,
it may be in reason chair technology may
have,
uh,
affected,
student,
the young,
young generation negatively in that
sense.
Maybe they have gotten less patients
perhaps,
uh,
when conducting research.
I don't know.
But uh,
see your attention span might not be as
good as it might be because of the
constant bombardment.
Exactly.
Okay.
Thank you.
Any more comments?
Well,
I think when these gentlemen probably
started out,
they had only a couple of journals
hardcopy whereas we have basically the
entire Internet.
So I think you just have to have a
better filter,
but still great,
great breakthrough with,
as you mentioned,
don't come around like every other week.
That doesn't happen.
I think nowadays year have often the
impression that you have so many options
and alternatives that might be a bit
hard to focus on one specific goal.
I do think that one of the most
important challenges for the educational
system nowadays is to teach students how
to select information that they can
found find on the internet,
and in that sense it's very important to
be able to use the media as an
opportunity rather than a threat.
What's the phrase that does seem to be a
bit of a kind of generational divide I
think,
or how people approach their work today
and how you ordered?
Yes.
I don't think it's as dramatic as being
described because we,
we're not faced with two journals,
but benny journals and we were faced
with having to read these journals
rather than to access them quickly.
We had to go to library,
so it was much more time consuming than
it is today.
You can get information much more
quickly today,
which is good.
Then you think that you just got his
time going to the library and that kind
of thing.
Bengt Holmstrom as an economist,
what's your here?
I don't think we think very much about
Nobel prizes when we do our research.
So I think the key is who is the nature
of research and how it's evolving.
So it gets to the issue about has it
sped up or something like that.
And uh,
in economics at least,
uh,
despite all the journals,
it turns out that it's harder and takes
longer to get publications.
But maybe the whole functional
publications has changed.
The Internet started with physicist
circulating their papers at cern.
So the,
um,
now there's a huge overload of papers
coming in there with the branch,
geophysics.
Uh,
everything is put on the archive for
most immediately.
And of course it's,
it used to be easy to read what was put
out every day or every month,
but now there's so much coming in.
Again,
you get down to this filtering problem.
It facilitates our work,
no doubt.
But I missed something,
which is to read an article by accident
40 years ago.
I used to his,
you know,
and to take a journal,
just walls and all of a sudden,
you know,
you find a nice drawing.
Uh,
you read the paper,
you read it more in detail and this is
totally accidental and it's a good
accident nowadays.
You read what you are prepared to read,
you go to a journal on the Internet and
just look at what you want to look at.
There are no accidents anymore.
Senate serendipity,
serendipity and always that.
Thank you.
Well,
some interesting thoughts there,
but let's,
um,
now take some of our first questions
from the audience and Rebecca Loudin
your question please.
So I remember when I was supposed to
choose a degree for university,
that basic signs was not a very popular
field to go into among the students in
my class.
So how do you think we could encourage
more young people to be interested in
and wanting to pursue a career in basic
science and uh,
put silver,
uh,
recent studies and surveys to show that
nowadays,
young scientists are under extreme,
uh,
extremely high pressure to publish,
to secure funding and a tenure track
positions.
And this often leaves serve very little
energy and time to,
um,
to do high quality research and to
pursue interest in ideas.
So what is your perspective on this?
And you end pen.
Okay.
My question is,
um,
what is your opinion towards a global
trend of reducing funding for
fundamental fundamental science
research?
Thank you very much.
Let's take that last question first from
UN pan about the global trend.
He says reduced funding for fundamental
scientific research.
So Fraser,
I mean,
do you see a difference in,
in the research were fundamental and
applied scientific research?
Yeah,
no I don't.
I think there is no difference between
fundamental research and applied
research.
I think there's only good research and I
think the two marriage into each other
very nicely.
I spent time in industry and did some
very fundamental work when I was with
imperial chemical industries,
corporate laboratory.
And that is where most of the ideas that
led to my,
uh,
discoveries in the early nineties came
from.
So,
uh,
I've never seen,
this,
uh,
the mnr situation.
I've just seen good research and maybe
not so good research.
Judge my,
you'd like to pick up some of those
points that we heard.
Yeah.
Um,
people talk a lot about,
um,
the pressure to get tenure.
I mean that you have to do a lot to get
tenure and that makes people write a lot
and all that.
But actually I,
when I look around and see my colleagues
who've got tenure,
many of them also seem to continue to
produce many papers.
And I think the reason they do it so
they don't read it,
they're not under the prior the garden
anymore,
but they still do it.
It's not just to get grants,
it's because I think to some extent they
like to feel busy and they like to be
able to tell people what they're doing.
And actually it's quite difficult to be
engaged in a longterm project because
then you know,
where you meet someone,
they say,
what are you up to?
Well,
not much.
You know,
nothing
in places it doesn't set in.
Once they got the 10 year put their feet
up.
No,
no.
Um,
but the,
the thing is I'm not,
I think that you,
you would hope they would then say,
oh,
I'm now free to do a 10 year project.
But I think it's
mentally difficult to do that.
I always give my students that want to
go into an academic career,
the following at fry's walk on two feet,
one going align of research,
but at least you get some decent paper
so that you can ride a grant application
or people recognize that you do some
decent work and then work also on some
fairly challenging question on where you
might not have a paper in the next three
or four or five years,
but where you will make a name in the
world for yourself.
Of course that's risky.
The debt will stay said the states maybe
for your next career.
So yeah,
you cannot deny that there is a pressure
to publish some papers because we had
our papers.
You might not have the possibility to
get a grant or the next step or 10 year
or so,
but you should focus on what are
important questions because we forget
that sometimes they're,
the main purpose of science is to ask
the right questions.
So about all this information and
knowledge is,
it's great to know a lot,
but it's better to ask the right
questions.
Professor Castilla it's one question was
how do we encourage more young people to
go into science?
It's,
I think that's a very difficult thing to
do because if you think about it from
an,
most people are going to science,
okay they go in very enthusiastic study
harder,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But the chances of being very successful
are actually law and so you'll never
going to get rich for example of Eh
maybe chemistry medicine and so it's
different.
But certainly in physics you'll never
get rich doing it.
So why do you know you've bought your
prize now that your well actually
reached the very top and then a little
bit anxious.
Yeah,
it's wonderful to have this price.
But if you think about is monetary value
is monthly values,
not much.
Not after the tax man as as had this cup
has had is cut.
So the money's not the thing.
It's more the satisfaction of doing,
of producing something in physics.
But how do you know which piece of
information is is significant and which
is not something 99.9%
of the stuff out there is not so
significant.
This is noise and the one and the 0.1%
that is significant out there.
You've got to know it significant.
How do you know what significant,
you have to be familiar with the
subject.
So it's,
it's,
it's a very difficult problem.
You obviously have identified that north
0.1%.
I think one of the things that's
overlooked in this conversation is that
mentoring is very important.
It's a,
and when you ask,
you know,
how can we improve the on the system?
I think if we maintain a good mentoring
system that is critical and I don't
think these other things that much it
came through from your comment about,
uh,
about,
you know,
giving advice to students.
So I have been,
I would say I've been very lucky to have
wonderful mentors,
one of which sits in the audience here,
having good colleagues and so on.
And I think looking at it as a monetary
issue or,
or,
or Korea concern is,
is just far too narrow and is your
mental health.
But Wilson is sitting in the corner.
They,
all right.
Put your hand up top is not just my
mentor.
He's a mentor of many,
many find students and a two Nobel prize
winners.
He looks really young to be a mentor.
But anyway,
thank you.
Our next question please.
From Kerstin
blend,
uh,
recently it seems as though governments
and the general public are rejecting
experts and ignoring their advice.
Where in the past it was held in much
higher esteem.
Uh,
what do you think is driving this trend?
Bengt Holmstrom you worried about
experts,
advice being rejected by public opinion.
I'm worried about the public rejecting
the,
not just the experts,
but it's what our representatives and
have the ability or should have the
ability to process complex information.
And today's situation seems to be
characterized by people thinking that
they can go directly to the source and
not have anybody interpret it and
therefore they are very subject,
very much subject to misunderstanding
what is going on.
And uh,
and so yes,
I'm very rarely it is though the complex
this use this be understood by the
experts in ordinary people in they're
capable of working it out themselves.
Here's where the lead is,
doesn't mean in this context that it
needs to be bad.
So this is,
this is really part of our democratic
system that there are some people who
know more than the others and not
before,
not necessarily because they're smarter
or anything like that,
but they have just been handed the task
to process the information on a broader
basis.
And what seems to be happening now is as
total total almost ejection two four for
this principle.
You know,
I think some of the,
I don't want to call it distrust of
experts,
but sort of working around them isn't so
bad.
I mean,
for example,
you know,
once upon a time,
if there was anything wrong with you,
went to the doctor and you assume that
what the doctor was telling you is the
truth.
Now you can go on the Internet and find
out,
get a lot of information about what
might be wrong with you.
And I think that can be actually
productive.
Sometimes you can end up knowing more
than the doctor about a particular thing
or,
but at least being able to bring to
their attention something.
Um,
I think there's a difference between
that and um,
you know,
if,
if you go on the web and you look at
things carefully and you might even read
some articles so you don't want to
exaggerate your competence to understand
them,
but you can get a sense of it.
Um,
I mean that's a good thing.
And,
and figure if you did that say with
global warming,
you would undoubtedly end up with the
conclusion that the science says this is
a really serious problem.
What's worrying is when people find
somebody who says it's not a problem and
focuses,
you know,
they then focus on that.
Yeah.
There's a whole tsunami of information.
The real point that we are all facing is
of course,
quality of information.
What does it mean?
How are we going to educate our young
people to distinguish what is right?
How are we to eh,
Eh,
eh,
making information available to the
general public and probably be a
scientist.
I have to do a much better job to
distinguish facts from fiction and
opinions.
You cannot develop a smartphone based on
an opinion.
It's the phrase,
I mean specifically on this,
the brexit vote.
Um,
and you know,
experts and politicians seeing their
advice rejected that that caused you a
great deal of angst.
Y
it did.
If we were going to enter an era of hard
brexit,
then this is almost like a chemical
reaction that is close to irreversible.
And that saddens me.
I was at the forefront,
I feel when I was in the UK,
in Sheffield and latterly in Birmingham,
bringing in students from all over
Europe and then all around the world.
When I left to go to United States,
we were something and the excess of 15
different nationalities in a group of 30
to 40 people.
This was sheer magic.
The switched on the,
uh,
students,
from the British isles in a remarkable
way as well as,
uh,
you know,
really raise the standard of our
research.
And so I'm saddened by the fact that,
uh,
the,
people working,
uh,
in chemistry at the highest level in the
UK could be faced in the near time by
having to go down to pooling on a
population of 65 million instead of 500
million.
Can I send you that?
We happy with what you heard?
I mean,
what's the answer to your own question?
Oh,
I suppose,
um,
I mean for me during my phd has been
invaluable in,
um,
allowing me to consider how the
scientific process happens,
how to approach something as a skeptic
and to look at the evidence.
And I think,
I feel like that's something that's
missing perhaps in,
in the general public's mindset.
They,
uh,
tend to,
take what the media gives them and
ingest that rather than perhaps being as
critical as it should be.
Yep.
Thank you very much indeed.
Okay,
so we'll go to your specific fields.
Um,
and now gentlemen,
for which he won the prize and let us
start with them.
In economics.
Professor Horton,
professor homes strong,
the Nobel Committee said you won the
prize for your separate work on contract
theory.
The judges said your work late an
intellectual foundation for policies in
areas such as where the workers should
receive a bonus incentive or ordinary
salary where the essential public
services should be privatized.
And they said there was,
these were matters valuable to the
understanding of real life contracts and
institutions.
Um,
Oliver Hart,
you see parallels between your work on
incomplete contracts,
what I could turn bad contracts and why
people in the UK voted brexit.
How does your work on contract theory
explain the Brexit vote?
I don't want to say it's explains it,
but I,
there are parallels because,
um,
in my work I've looked at contracts
between two commercial parties and I've
argued that in,
in situations where it's hard to write a
good contract,
um,
what becomes very important is who gets
to decide on the things missing from the
contract.
I call that residual control rights.
And that sometimes goes together with
ownership of assets.
Now in the political context,
if we,
if we take,
you can think of the European Union,
the arrangement that the co all the
countries have in the European Union,
it's like a contract.
Uh,
and you could have,
you could imagine in a sort of ideal
world,
um,
that everything would be written down in
advance and then the whole European
Union would just have been about the
negotiation of that initial contract.
Well,
of course that's not,
you can't do that.
So instead you set up these decision
making bodies and I think that what the
British voters fault was,
they'd allocated a lot of that power,
that residual or authority to the center
Brussels as call it a way from the
individual countries.
And I think people pass felt they had
done too much of that.
By the way.
I am was in favor of remain.
I didn't want,
I didn't thought it,
sorry.
Year brexit where you all opposed to it
including the two Europeans,
Dutch and French.
We all opposed to brexit.
Yes.
Interesting.
All are Nobel laureates at the table for
a few British to European say you're all
opposed to brexit.
Okay.
Banks home throw your research,
looks at whether contract incentives,
how contract incentives affect corporate
behavior and you know,
whether performance related pay works
and the difficulties in assessing say a
teacher's performance as you said,
it's not as easy to is to measure as a
factory worker and how many goods or
handbags or whatever they may have
manufactured.
So in terms of the workplace,
what does your research into contract
theory tell us?
I think the big insight in some in my
view is
that uh,
we were very focused initially on,
on thinking I incentives need to be
provided by financial instruments of
some kind of others or contract.
And we have come to understand how big a
part of incentives is actually something
entirely different than what most people
think as incentives like bonuses or
something like that.
So
constantly throwing money at people
doesn't necessarily
just a matter of money.
But yes,
the,
the sort of stereotype view is,
is throwing money at people or you know,
there's an incentive problem,
let's incentivize them be some money.
Actually that is most definitely not the
main,
main approach the world takes.
Maybe when we have all these debates,
particularly in the UK about executive
pay and um,
executives getting big bonuses and
salaries because share prices have gone
up in their company or whatever.
What's your answer to that?
Does it not make economic sense to pay
these big checks?
Okay.
It's not so much how big they are.
Uh,
I mean size matters,
but what worries me much more is how
they get structured and especially what
these candles and other things have
caught have led to in terms of how they
are designed.
So I think,
I think we have gone from some arrows
that could have been correct.
It's a 20 years ago or so,
uh,
in the designs into much worse designs
because of uh,
the public being upset and the
regulators being upset and they are
trying to really solve the problem.
We'll levels and not thinking so much
about the incentives.
So,
uh,
I think we are gone from,
from maybe a somewhat flawed system to a
much better system.
Also moving to another area of research
that you are watered your price for with
this question of whether for public
providers of services,
whether they could be privatized.
For instance,
the Obama Administration to the prison
service which was privatized,
should no longer be provided by a
private companies.
It was to see a live debate in Africa
for instance,
about whether education should be
publicly provided or provided by the
private sector.
So Professor Hart,
I mean,
what,
what does economics tell us?
Well,
I think it can be helpful.
I wrote a paper with causes about this
issue and I think,
you know,
what we say in the paper is,
um,
you know,
one extreme would you privatized nuclear
weapons?
We thought no.
I mean put them in private hands.
Didn't seem like I have a contract with
someone who holds the nuclear weapons.
Probably not a good idea.
Um,
would you prioritize the State
Department?
Would you have a contract with a private
company to run foreign policy?
Um,
I dunno whether Donald Trump is thinking
along those lines,
but I don't think,
I don't think that would be a good idea.
Ah,
he has appointed a businessman,
I think so maybe he's moving in that
direction.
But um,
at the other extreme garbage collection,
rubbish collection,
quite comfortable with that.
It depends how good a contract you can,
right?
And,
but you know,
what kind of things can go wrong and
therefore who should have the residual
control rights.
That's it.
But that's how to think about these
things.
Right?
Schools or somewhere in between,
in between when you have competition
that strengthens the case for
privatization.
So in the case of schools,
um,
you know,
if a school does badly is shading on
quality,
then people will eventually find out,
it may take a bit of time,
but you know,
and they'll send their kids to a
different school.
In the case of prisoners,
we probably don't think it would be a
great idea for the prisoners to be able
to shop around.
And so,
you know,
their competition isn't going to work as
well.
And that strengthens the case from
public provision.
Thank you very much.
So,
and I just turn to a chemistry and the
chemistry,
uh,
Laurie,
it's the three of you were jointly
awarded the prize for fundamental
chemistry.
The Nobel Committee said,
do you have mastered motion control at
the molecular scale,
the design and synthesis of machines a
thousand times thinner than a strand of
hair so small that tens of thousands of
them could actually fit on a pinhead.
So we've got,
um,
some questions I think from the students
here.
If I could have the first one all off.
Yonson your question.
Yeah.
So what are the fundamental limits to
how small you could make these
artificial molecular machines?
Okay,
great.
If we could take the next one,
Hilda Bucklin ah,
so I wonder,
uh,
in 20 years time or do you think you'll
see the biggest use?
So molecular robots a word,
for example,
be in medicine or molecular electronics.
Thank you ben for anger.
Let me take the first one with you.
What are the fundamental limits to how
small you can make an artificial
molecular machine?
Cause in 1999 you led the first research
to produce a molecular motor that
continually spins in the same direction.
And then in 2011 year old group built a
four wheel drive for Nano car.
Yeah,
it's very difficult to say what the
limits were doing,
but we work with molecules and typically
our molecular motor is half a nanometer
also.
So and one nanometers,
1000000000th of a meter,
as you know.
So the limits will be probably a dead
size,
but you have to realize if you want to
build machines,
it's only the moving part is only part
of the machine.
So you have to integrate it.
For instance,
you have to put it on the servers or
integrate in a device,
et cetera.
So that is,
that all depends on the type of
molecules you are designing for a
specific purpose.
If you look in your eye,
which has a beautiful switch,
it is the tiny molecule in the NDI is
probably one and we do,
but it's part of a big protein complex
that makes it possible that the signal
of the light that comes to your eyes
triggers this.
In your eye and then changes and there's
a cascade of process that make it
possible that you get the signal in your
brain.
The fact that I can see you,
when you can see me,
the fact that all cells can define that
became move on muscles.
These are machines of a,
of a couple of nanometers at most.
Sean via survives.
You mean you managed to meet one
molecule,
Piro at,
around the other in a controlled manner
when energy was applied.
So our question about where do you see
the biggest use of molecular robots in
medicine or molecular electronics?
The question was what's your answer to
make it clear?
I have no answer.
I have,
I have comments.
Um,
uh,
before our contributions,
um,
it was considered as extremely difficult
to set molecular systems in motion.
I mean,
we knew everybody knew that there were
plenty of such motors and machines in
the biological world,
but using artificial systems,
molecules,
which had been made in a laboratory that
was considered almost impossible.
And I think that was a big step in a way
that,
uh,
the three of us and our coworkers,
just the question or I assume is,
is,
is thinking won't hit.
Yeah.
But when she asked about medicine is
that,
you know,
we think about the walking microscopic
robots,
which could for instance,
slip inside the human body and deliver
drugs in a targeted manner.
Yeah.
Perhaps perhaps it's a phrase it,
so the question we had about any,
do you foresee any negative social or
environmental challenges with the misuse
of this technology that we should be
aware of?
An,
I should say that you made a key advance
by threading and molecular ring onto a
rod like structure that acted as a dumb
bell.
The kind of thing we use in the gym.
When you added the two together,
the ring jumped forwards and backwards
like a tiny shuttle and later you've
built numerous molecular machines.
I'm including a pump.
So that was your particular
contribution.
But what's your answer to the question?
Well if I could tell you the latter part
first and just make a comment about the
movement to ban for ringer has promoted
the movement in a circular sensor,
rotary [inaudible].
So I think John Pierre and I with our
um,
taxing based systems,
a molecular shotwell based systems have
done the fundamental preliminary work to
achieve movement in a linear direction.
But it's not just sufficient to have
that movement in a willy nilly takeaway.
We have got to be able to direct that
movement.
The first step after you have
the Willy Nilly type of movement is to
go to a switch.
There's still a lot to be done in terms
of going from switches to machines,
machines have to do work and uh,
this has been a progressive situation
from finding how to bring a bank this
motion in either a rotary or a linear
rate direction to a switch to a machine.
Would you like to see opportunities in,
in your,
either discoveries you've me,
would you like to see them develop,
I mean Bedford and go,
do you see great opportunities
since I,
I definitely say great opposition is my
colleagues already said it is very,
very early days.
So this is fundamental research.
The breakthrough that you can induce
motion responsive functions in materials
opens up an entirely new field of
material science and machines.
Ultimately maybe science fiction at this
moment,
but in 30,
40,
50 years from now,
I see many opportunities during my whole
career.
I work together with industry also on
potential applications.
Uh,
and,
and so we have close contact then and
when we,
and this counts for,
for the whole community,
I think if we see opportunities for
cooperation,
we will work together with industries.
But you have to realize to bring it to a
product in the market.
My take along development or the
directory,
develop a new medicine at this moment
takes more than 12 years and,
uh,
lots of money.
So this is typically the timeframe we
are working in.
It turns out in my laboratory in recent
times by working in this area,
we have serendipitously gone off in two
completely different directions.
One is to create very highly porous
materials that,
uh,
as the basis for one startup company
starting about 15 months ago,
that is looking at,
uh,
use of,
these polars materials in home care,
in personal care,
in food,
and ultimately in pharmaceuticals.
And the other one is quite serendipitous
discovery that I would never have even
predicted.
And that is that we are looking at a new
ways of isolating gold that get us away
from the use of cyanide,
which is 83% of the world's isolation.
And the other 17% is mercury,
two very nasty chemicals.
And all of this has come out to
fundamental research and most of these
are seven deputies discoveries going on
while we're making molecular machines.
Thank you.
All right,
thank you very much indeed.
Chemists,
Laurie.
So turning to the laureates in physics,
um,
Duncan Hall Day,
Michael Costa,
Litz and also David soulless or all of
your British born and uh,
David solders.
Professor Thalamus is not with us,
but our congratulations go to him.
Also,
you were jointly awarded the prize for
discoveries for your pioneering work on
strange forms of matter.
The Nobel Committee said your
discoveries,
it opened the door on an unknown world.
Now Mike hostile,
it's along with David Thallus.
You focused on that arise in flat forms
of matter on surfaces inside extremely
thin layers that can be considered two
dimensional,
unlike the three dimensions that are,
you know,
we describe reality around us with and
the work involves a field of maths known
as topology topology basically I suppose
analyzes the sheep of things.
It's a,
tells us that a doe not in a wedding
ring topologically are the same thing.
And do you Duncan of all,
Danes studied one dimensional matters.
So that's the kind of preface to the
question that we have from our physics
student.
A flora couldn't stop.
Yes.
Um,
do you think there will be any
technological advancements such as,
for instance,
quantum computers coming from the new
insights in quantum mechanics separate
provided by Ortiz?
Most probably,
yes.
I mean to what we really discovered was,
uh,
the,
there were more interesting materials
than we expected.
And um,
condensed matter physics is a fancy name
for understanding the properties of
materials and what this work is a really
led to,
it started off with one dimensional
things,
but it's not just one dimensional or two
dimensional.
There are a class of materials which we
didn't realize existed before that have
a very interesting properties,
uh,
in the quantum mechanical structure.
And the quantum mechanics is a
fundamental way to understand all
materials.
And a,
the topology is a side issue in a sense
that we discovered the,
some very beautiful,
unexpected properties of quantum
mechanics and the mathematical tools of
Topology,
uh,
turned out to be very useful for
analyzing the specific differences
between these unexpected forms of matter
and conventional matter.
So this whole analog about Brett's
pretzels and bagels is just that the
Bagel has a hole in it.
It's different from a football which
doesn't,
and this a new form of new kinds of
condensed matter.
Uh,
also different from the familiar types
as the Bagel is for the football.
The,
the property of having the whole in the
Bagel makes it slightly different.
You can,
you know,
pick up the Beagle and it can get,
you can look through it,
you can poke your finger through it or
whatever.
But it's just different.
It's not good for playing football with,
no,
it's not good for playing football,
but it will change the game as I said.
Right.
So professor Costa lists and we have
heard that your work could result in
improved materials for electronics and
that could lead to super fast computers.
Okay.
So this is,
it doesn't like the question.
No,
no,
it's not.
No,
like it,
I just fumbling for an answer to that
because let me,
let me stress that when we,
when
we started this work,
it was,
we had no thoughts about applications or
anything like that.
It was nothing more than an interesting
theoretical problem.
There was a,
you know,
there was,
there was a theoretical question that we
wanted to try to answer and that's what
started it all.
Sure.
Could it,
I mean in theory we can see all the
difficulties as well as some of the,
the possibilities.
And the question was asking about the
possibilities.
Duncan,
I can see many of the difficulties we
unanswered difficulties,
right?
So we simply don't know the answer to
the question.
Well,
leave the physics there then.
Could we go to our next uh,
question please end gala link off.
Hi.
Um,
so we've all noticed that there are no
women,
um,
the received the Nobel prize this year.
Uh,
so my question is what can you ask noble
laureates us as young scientists but
also general public do to encourage
women to go into science and promote
them.
Okay,
well a volunteer to start that one.
My own view of this,
this issue is initial,
no question about it,
but my own view of this issue is a bit
heretical.
And you see to me the,
the female of the species is actually v
too smart to go into physics simply
because physics is tough education,
no question about it.
And the,
the,
the resulting,
uh,
job you going to get with this fancy
education is not great.
It doesn't pave particularly well and it
doesn't give you much free time.
So why on earth should somebody who's,
uh,
who,
who is sensible and intelligent go into
this difficult field when they can make
a much better living in these your
fields.
So heretical that your fellow laureates
green shakes.
My view is heretical.
Fantastic job if you,
cause it gives you the opportunity to,
uh,
discover things and to work on advancing
knowledge.
Now if you want to people,
it's not badly paid.
I disagree that it's bad.
It's not,
I mean people that if you want to make a
huge amounts of money,
of course you go to Wall Street or
whatever.
But,
uh,
the issue with a women in physics,
I mean physics departments certainly in
that you states,
uh,
vary tremendously focused on,
I'm trying to do something about this.
Uh,
the,
uh,
we believe probably it's a question of
maybe it's role models to be able to see
a successful women scientists.
And so people believe that they can have
a career in it.
We really do wish women to come into
physics.
And,
uh,
there's a problem of,
of,
of women becoming discouraged and
dropping out at each stage of the
process.
These are experiments that they have
done in,
in Addis and sob musicians.
And they have started toward this and
behind the curtain it changes
dramatically the motto and the number of
women that they are accepted.
So it just shows the days a lot of
discrimination and it's not a evil
disagreements a side.
I think it's just subconscious.
We are a club,
you know,
we men behave in a certain way.
We understand each other better.
We don't understand why men very well,
you know.
So Fraser,
your late wife was a scientist.
Yes.
As we all your two daughters.
What's your answer on this?
Gender risky.
Why does it happen that we don't have
enough women?
And what can you do about it?
Well,
I think it's a changing environment and
um,
I think we will see over the next 50
years a dramatic change.
If I spec express it in terms of my own
family,
I think my two daughters who are sitting
in this audience with phds in chemistry
are,
um,
living in a much different social and
home background.
And even myself and my wife where they
are supported by a husbands who are
playing a big role in running the
family,
looking after the children.
And so I think we've seen social changes
that will make it very much easier for
women to participate in the,
uh,
follow the rules of science.
Um,
and so I'm very optimistic that it's
going to come about maybe one year in
the future there'll be seven women
sitting around this table,
optimistic comments.
And I think we can end that particular
area of Asher just want to end by saying
of course.
Um,
normally we would hope to be joined at
the table by the laureate for literature
and this air force.
It was a Bob Dylan.
I should also say,
actually,
of course we don't have with us
Professor Yoshinori Ohsumi who is the
Nobel laureate in medicine or physiology
and dark.
Congratulations.
Go to him too.
But in terms of Bob Dylan,
um,
there have been some comments saying
that the songwriter perhaps shouldn't
have been considered in this category of
a literature prize.
John,
Pierre,
you reacted this.
So what do you think
our law,
I like him as a senior.
I liked the music,
but I also have difficulties to believe
that,
uh,
there are no writers,
you know,
very recalling,
recognized as writers who don't deserve
the pies as well.
All right.
Very diplomatic answer.
Perhaps a thing that,
uh,
anybody else bumped into.
Yeah,
I think it's fantastic that Bob Dylan
got this award.
I mean,
he,
his poems,
his songs were so important and
influential for whole generation.
You know,
when I was a student,
I had these records and I still know
every one of it.
It's,
it's great.
And when it was announced in a typical
laboratory like mine,
every Laborde,
he has his own music and
within a minute they all switched to Bob
Dylan.
Oh,
really?
He said he was speechless when he
received being awarded.
The one
that's it's influence is boards
influence people,
you know,
what,
it seems to me that's later.
Okay.
Good Choice Professor Castilla it's,
I think you're a big fan of personal
point of view.
When I heard that the literature prize
being awarded to bop little,
I thought,
wow,
that's the greatest decision I've ever
heard of.
Why I love Dylan and his and his music
and songs.
I really grew up,
I essentially grew up with it.
Do you do Karaoke for Bob didn't have
Bob Dylan.
I once I once tried it,
I mean I can't see,
you don't want to give us a nice town.
Absolutely not.
Mac can't sing
heretical to say about Bob Dylan,
which is,
I think we've spent far too much time
talking about Bob Dylan.
Well,
I don't mean here,
right?
I mean,
just generally,
you know,
is he calming?
Isn't it you calming?
I actually don't care.
I mean,
he didn't come.
I mean it seems to me I have,
it may have been a fine choice,
but uh,
um,
probably if he had come he would have
sucked all the oxygen out of the event.
So this is partly,
I think,
good thing he didn't.
Well,
I show 'em take up your recommendation
and stop talking about any factions,
a movie.
We'll stop talking about anything.
Thank you to all you laureates and
renewed congratulations.
Thank you to our audience here of the
concert hall in Stockholm,
and thank you to you.
Of course.
Um,
wherever you are in the world watching
this program for me,
Zane Abu Dhabi and the rest of the team
or Nobel Mines,
goodbye.